he was my first sexual relationship as
he was a number of my fraternity
brothers he asked me if I'd come back to
his apartment at 3 o'clock in the
morning I said what was that all about
you and the congressman and he said said
we're having a relationship he grabbed
me by the shoulder and very boldly said
remember you never saw me
you've never been here he had a
relationship with him a sexual
relationship with him we never discussed
his political platform or what he
believed in we just had sex let me be
clear I am not gay
there are names in to folks in the
Congress and high positions of power who
are leading a secret double life they
have been chasing us for years we're
gonna chase back I think that each one
of these outings puts a little [__] in
the armor of the anti-gay movement it is
very important that the people who make
the law be subject to the law 90 percent
of the cases or so are Republicans he is
dancing at flamingo on the weekend and
propping up the most right-wing
homophobes in America same thing I was
doing as a teenager bashing other gay
people in order to prove that they're
not gay this is your voting record and
it seems to run absolutely contradictory
to the way you've lived your personal
life you know what the right value is
the right value is truthfulness the
right value is honest
you